[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نشا القارئ محمود جمال في محافظه الجيزه
بمصر في اكناف اسره حافظه للقران الكريم
حفظ القران في كتاتيب قريته قبل التحاقه
بالمعهد الديني الازهري ليتعلم التجويد
واحكامه قبل تخرجه من كليه اللغات
والترجمه بجماعه الازهر الشريف بتفوق اهله
لتولي الامامه والخطابه في عدد من المساجد
دون انقطاع عن حفظ القران ونيل الاجازات
في قراءته الحمد لله ربنا انعم علي باسره
طيبه
باب وام كانوا وما زالوا الحمد لله ربنا
يحفظهم
يحافظون على القران الكريم
وربونا وانشؤون على حفظ القران وعلى حب
القران وعلى فهم معاني القران الكريم
والدي حفظه الله يعني كان ومازال الى الان
يوصيني بمراجعه القران الكريم
والبدايه كانت
منذ الطفوله حيث التحقت بالمعهد الديني
الازهري بالقريه
وكنت التحقت ايضا في كتاب القريه
لاحد المشايخ العظام في القريه
وختمت القران على يديه وذلك ايضا بمساعده
ابي وامي في ان احفظ معهما وان اذهب للشيخ
وان اكرر عليه ما حفظته مره اخرى واصحح
عليه التلاوه ثم اعود الى البيت وهكذا حتى
حفظت القران مع ابي وامي ومع الشيخ رحمه
الله شيخي حفظت اولا على يد شيخي الشيخ
عبد الحافظ ابو سنه هو كان احد مشايخ
القريه الاجلاء الذين كان لهم حرص شديد
على تعليم القران الكريم
لابناء القريه وهب نفسه
لذلك وبعد ذلك بعد ان
ختمت القران على يدي انتقلت بعد ذلك الى
حفظ القران
وتعلم وتعلم التجويد واحكام التلاوه
التجويد واخذ الاجازه على يد شيخي الثاني
شيخ احمد عبد الغفور ابو سنه وهو ايضا
رحمه الله منذ سنوات قليله وهو هذا الشيخ
اخذني وكان حريصا اشد الحرص على ان اخذ
الاجازه بالاسناد المتصل على يديه منه الى
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
فاخذت القران الكريم عليه على يديه ثم بعد
ذلك انتقلت الى مشايخ القريه
ح اتممت ختم القران
وصار متقنا ومجودا على يد الشيخ احمد عبد
الغفور تدرجت بعد ذلك الى ان انت
اقرات القران وسمعت القران على معظم شيوخ
قريتنا الاجلاء وعلى راسهم فضيله الشيخ
خالد ابو سنه حفظه الله وكثير من المشايخ
في القريه بارك الله فيهم وايضا هذا بجانب
دراسته في المعهد الديني الازهري حيث كان
من الضروري حفظ القران وختم القران
الحمد لله كان من المفترض ان اختم القران
في الثانويه لكن بفضل الله الله اكرمني
وختمت القران وانا في سن الحاديه عشر في
المرحله الابتدائيه قبل ان اختم قبل ان
ابدا المرحله الاعداديه
والحمد لله يعني ربنا انعم علي ايضا بصحبه
طيبه في القريه من المشايخ والعلماء
دربوني على الخطابه والامامه
وانت تنقلت بين المساجد
والمساجد القريه ثم بعد ذلك بعد ان انهيت
مرحله الثانويه انتقلت الى القاهره
للدراسه في جامعه الازهر في كليه لغات
والترجمه
وهناك كانت رحله جديده مع العلماء علماء
الازهر وكبار علماء الازهر حيث تلقيت على
يد كبار المشايخ وعلماء الازهر الشريف
على راسهم يعني الحمد لله ربنا انعم علي
وجلست بين يدي فضيله الدكتور علي جمعه في
كم درس من الدروس
وايضا ايه جلست معه كثير من كبار علماء
الازهر الشريف
كاستاذنا وسيدنا ومولانا فضيله الدكتور
يسري جبر وهو من علماء الازهر الشريف كذلك
فضيله الدكتور استاذنا الدكتور جمال فاروق
وهو كان عميد كليه الدعوه حفظه الله وهو
هذا يعني هؤلاء العلماء
وكذلك فضيله الدكتور احمد ممدوح وهو في
منصب عالي جدا في امانه الفتوى في دار
الافتاء المصريه فتلقيت على يدها هؤلاء
الكوكبه يعني هذا بجانب الدراسه في الكليه
الحمد لله يعني كان عاده العلماء
المشايخ الذين حفظت على ايديهم القران
واخذت عنهم الاسانيد
كان من عاداتهم انهم زرعوا فينا هذه
الغريزه وهي اننا نقدم رساله للناس وانه
ليس مجرد حفظ قران ولكن هو هناك دراسه
لمعاني القران وهناك في
صله روحيه وهي من خلال الاسانيد المتصله
سلسله الاسناد نحن نتلقى عن شيخ عن شيخ
حتى نصل الى اعلى رتبه النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم ومنه الى
جبريل الى ثم الى ملك الملوك سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى فهذه السلسله
هذه في حد ذاتها تعطينا
دفعه وطاقه ايجابيه
وروح معنويه تجعلنا ننطلق يعني بين الناس
وتشجعنا ان نحن نستمر على ان نوصل هذه
الرساله الى غيرنا والى من نلتقي بهم فهم
لم يعلمونا فقط كلمات وايات ولكن علمونا
روح القران
وتعاليم القران التي ينبغي ان
نوصلها لغيرنا حتى يعم هذه الروح وهذه
الصله التي بين العدو وبين ربه فلا بد ان
نحرص عليها ايضا في اثناء رحلاتنا
وتنقلاتنا يحضرني الان بعض الايات من سوره
الانعام اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
قلت تعالوا اتلوا ما حرم ربكم عليكم
الا تشركوا به شيئا
[موسيقى]
وبالوالدين احسانا
ولا تقتلوا
اولادكم من
املاق نحن نرزقكم
واياهم
ولا تقربوا الفواحش ما ظهر منها وما بطن
ولا
تقتلوا النفس التي حرم الله الا بالحق
ذلكم وصاكم به لعلكم تعقلون
ولا تقربوا ما لم يتيم الا
بالتي هي احسن حتى يبلغ اشده
واوفوا الكيل
والميزان بالقسط لا نكلف نفسا الا وسعها
واذا قلتم فاعدلوا ولو كان ذا قربا
وبعهد الله اوفوا
ذلكم وصاكم به لعلكم
تذكرون
وان هذا صراط مستقيما
فاتبعوه ولا تتبعوا السبل فتفرق بكم
عن سبيله
ذلكم وصاكم به لعلكم تتق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اظهر القارئ محمود جمال نبوغا اهله للفوز
بمسابقه الازهر الشريف للمبتعثين الى
الخارج وكانت وجهته بعثه البرازيل التي حل
بها اماما في احد اكبر مساجدها وهو مسجد
سوفاور الكبير الذي يعد قبله للالاف من
ابناء الجاليه اللبنانيه ومركزا اجتماعيا
وثقافيا تقام فيه المناسبات والانشطه
لفائده المجتمع المحلي من المسلمين وغير
المسلمين ويقصده الطلاب الحاجه ممن تقطعت
بهم السبل خاصه من المهاجرين الجدد الى
هذه البلاد الحمد لله ربنا انعم علينا
بالازهر الشريف وانام علينا بفضيله الامام
الاكبر الاستاذ الدكتور احمد الطيب شيخ
الازهر الشريف هذا الذي يعني قضى حياته
وما زال في خدمه الدعوه وفي خدمه الاسلام
والمسلمين وفي نشر السلام في العالم اجمع
وهو حريص على
نشر ثقافه الاخوه الانسانيه في ربوع
العالم ليس في العالم الاسلامي فقط او في
العالم العربي فقط ولكن في العالم كله
وجهودهم ملموسه ولا احد ينكر فضله في هذا
الجانب وهو من حرصه على هذه
على هذا الامر انه
سخر كل الخدمات
لتيسير عمليه الابتعاد ابتعاد
علماء الازهر الشريف ومشايخ الازهر الشريف
الى دول العالم حتى ينشروا ثقافه السلام
من اجراءات هذه المسابقه هي مسابقه تعقد
سنويا عقيدها الازهر الشريف كل سنه وهذه
المسابقه لها اجراءات وشروط معقده جدا لا
يعني ليس كل شخص يدخلها ولكن هناك
خاصه بمن يبعث او يبتعث الى دول العالم
شاركت في هذه المسابقه وقد تقدمت اليها
ليس فقط بانني
خريج كليه شرعيه ولكن ايضا معي لغه فكانت
المسابقه لنا يحمل الجانب الشرعي العربي
والجانب الشرعي باللغه الانجليزيه فكنا
نعقد كل ما تم عقده من اختبارات
[موسيقى]
لزملائنا في الكليات العربيه نحن عقبنا
نفس الاختبارات ثم بالاضافه اليها
اختبارات خاصه باللغات حتى الحمد لله بفضل
الله نجحت في هذه المسابقه
والحمد لله ربنا انعم علي بانني جئت دوله
البرازيل اول المهام
هو نشر
الثقافه ثقافه الاسلام وتعريف الناس
بالاسلام لان هناك مفاهيم مغلوطه عن
الاسلام كما نعرف في
كثيره في العالم شوهت صوره الاسلام دور
الازهر او مبتعه الازهر الاساسي هو تصحيح
هذه الصوره وتعليم الناس الصوره الصحيحه
للاسلام
والقيام على خدمه الجاليات الاسلاميه في
البرازيل
والوقوف الى جانبهم والنظر الى ما يحتاجون
اليه من دراسات في العلوم المختلفه سواء
في دراسه القران وحفظ القران او في
دراسات الاحكام الفقهيه والتفسير والحديث
وغير ذلك من العلوم
بتاعه الازهر ايضا ان يكون في المسجد هو
يعني خادم للمسجد وخادم للقران وخادم لكل
ابناء الجاليات وظيفه الامام في دوله كهذه
الدوله دوله البرازيل تختلف
كثيرا عن الدوله التي هو فيها من حيث انه
لابد ان يظهر بالمظهر اللائق الذي يعبر عن
الاسلام هو ايضا يعني في بلده لابد ان
يظهر بهذا يعني وان يكون مخلصا امام الله
سبحانه وتعالى اولا وان يظهر بصوره سوره
القدوه هذا مع الجانب مع المسلمين الذين
هم مسلمين بالفعل لكن نحن في دوله فيها
غير مسلمين وهم يعرفون الاسلام من خلالنا
فبالتالي يكون العب اكبر والمسؤوليه اكثر
والجهد والاجتهاد في العمل يكون بشكل اكبر
فنحن نريد
للناس الصوره صوره الاسلام الصحيحه وان
نفند كل الشبهات التي تدور حول الاسلام
وكل المفاهيم المغلوطه حول الاسلام
ونشر ثقافه الوسطيه
منهج الاسلام الوسطي الذي يتبناه الازهر
الشريف الازهر ليس لا يتعصب لمذهب معين
ولكنه يسعى كل المذاهب الدينيه وايضا
يحترم كل الثقافات الاخرى ويرسخ جانب
القوه الانسانيه في التعامل مع الناس
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
هو الذي
ارسل رسوله بالهدى ودين الحق
ليظهره على الدين كله
وكفى بالله شهيدا
محمد رسول الله
محمد
رسول الله
والذين معهم اشد
على الكفار
رحم
اء بينهم
تراهم ركعا سجدا
يبتغون فضلا من الله
ورضوانا
سيماهم في وجوههم من اثر السجود
ذلك مثلهم في التوراه
ومثلهم في
الانجيل كزرع اخرج شطاه
فازرهم
فاستره
فاستغلظ فاستوى على سوقه
يعجب الزراع ليغيظ بهم الكفار
وعد الله الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
منهم
مغفره
واجرا عظيما
صدق الله العظيم
حينما اتيت البرازيل كنت متوقع يعني الا
يكون هناك اقبال في المسجد في رمضان ولكن
على عكس ما توقعت وجدت المسجد ما شاء الله
ممتلئ في رمضان
يعني عن اخره حتى في صلوات التراويح وحتى
وقت الافطار وصلوات التراويح يعني ما شاء
الله المسجد يعني به مصلون كثيرون وايضا
يعني في خلال النهار يعني حتى يعني نجد
الناس
يتوافدون على المسجد
وجدت جوا
رمضانيا عظيما في هذا المسجد
وهذا ايضا يرجع الفضل فيه الى الله اولا
ثم الى الجمعيه الخيريه الاسلاميه في مسجد
البرازيل التي توفر الخدمات لابناء
الجاليه وتوفر لهم الافطار اليومي في هذا
المسجد
وهذا فيه ايضا فيه نوع من التكافل
الاجتماعي وفي ايضا تشجيع الناس على
الحضور في رمضان وعلى خلق هذا الجو
الرمضاني جميل وايضا دروس التي
التي نعددها في مسجد البرازيل في رمضان هي
دروس ما شاء الله يعني
اعدها ايضا المسجد الجمعيه الخيريه وكذلك
فضيله الشيخ محمد البقاعي حيث ان هو وجدته
اعد البث المباشر في في وقت الافطار ووقت
صلاه القيام التراويح وقت ما بعد التراويح
ووقت السحور فهذه هذا البث المباشر خلق
جوا
رمضانيا جميلا جعل رمضان في في بيوتهم
ايضا يعني في بيوت معظم الناس الجاليه
التي لا تستطيع ان تاتي مسجد البرازيل
واجمل منك يا محمد لن تراقبت عين
واجمل منك لم تلد النس
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
اء
خلقت مبرا من كل
عين
[موسيقى]
كانك قد خلقت كما
قمر
[موسيقى]
سدنا النبي قمر وج
ميل وج
ميل وجميل سيدنا النبي وجميل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]